D LDIS RAC
FRANCA
NGOT IT.
TOWARDS ANNEI NER HAVE
VOLUNTAR
WNAS A
T WAOUT OF COMPASSIOWH
THOUGHE,EL
SENS.LAST POSTED AVOT ARE O OFTE
T NOT REMOVE TH
THPU RN, NOTIN
E LY CN OF
ADST BATTLE OF
RT OF THE SPENDING
PROVIDES
D AMNESTY FOR ATF IOOF ILLEGAL .
NS, DRUGANN
TRAFFICKERS ARE BEIN ANDLED NDTH
.
HRY E. PEOPLE E  VOICE
CO M
STN ALEXANDEAGAINSY L IEFE LAW -
PED HR
THANKY LLGNIZ
R HES RANG OUT IOLUTION. ASKED R
ANIMATED AMES  DERGE
KILLING A FELLOW MBE
D TTACKINGDE
BEFOREWAS TAKEWNATESTHATEEMIIOAV
VIOLENCEN ASCA
BASE.ASOOFTCASE FOR
LYTHDER
FO.E NORMALIZES VIOLENCE.ENINS T
ENTARIANS D 44%  RVED
THATTIS.INNTTHESN IS.
STRIEMWEM S HISTBLES
ANHIS OF
AND INSTRAACCOUNTS.T RET  E-MAI.
I.FANTILE.D  ON TO SAY THE
HYPERVENTILATING.
IT DOEE A ROCKET
S
REMORSACT, YNG N
OGE ORY OF THIS COUNTRY HAVE
CENSURED FOR ACTIONS
G THE SPEA
OR UAM GEUCDEPICTINRDERING ANOT
E  DEMOCRATHSATHIN THE
SAME RESOLUTION.
WITHHAT, I>> GENTL FROA.
MADAMEAKEASED TO ONE MINUTEE
.
MINUTE.
>>ME
MADAME SPE, YOU KNOWODAYOM
T O LONGER FEEL
TAY SI.ID
EPESENTATI G
RADAR IS ILLUSE OF THE
ITS DY
WHY MANY S HAVET NFIDENY
AMI >>EMORIDA.
EAKER,
LEN FROM
RHE NKORELMAJO LEADE
I RISERO STHURWATCHE V
. GOSAR PICTIN BODY,
AND BRANDISHSW UNITED STATES.
TING OF A
U.S. REPNT ANDN BEDEADLY, AS WE
SEF OO
THIS IS NOT A JOKENOAFETY.E ALY
WH